clic clic waouh tu fais hyper bien le
clic merci abonne toi
salut c'est 2022 norges de crohn ses
moyens par contre on est en 2011 de ça
c'est vrai dtc ça existe depuis 2016 et
je me suis dit que c'était le moment de
changer deux ou trois trucs mais avant
de commencer j'ai un premier truc à vous
dire pour plein de raisons que vous
allez comprendre plus tard j'ai décidé
d'ouvrir un compte youtube certaines et
certains me l'avait demandé j'ai un peu
hésité mais cette fois c'est ça ouais
c'est là c'était de voir si vous
connaissez pas du type c'est un moyen de
soutenir les créateurs dont vous aimez
le contenu donc moi du coup il ya
plusieurs moyens de le faire mais il y
en a deux principales en faire des dons
ou acheter des goodies ou les deux
heures si vous voulez donc n'hésitez pas
comme ça vous classe et puis moi ça me
fait plaisir et ça file un coup de main
sans parler après donc je disais détesté
ça existe depuis 2016 et depuis 2007 ce
qui s'est passé plein de trucs si on
avait parlé dans une vidéo sur le
détatouage sais pas si vous vous
souvenez une rupture et jallet mère est
morte ma grand-mère est morte
avait alors au passage pour tous les
gens qui continuent à me demander oui il
a disparu hanouna de mes fesses
seulement pour le moment alors
concrètement qu'est ce qui va changer le
décor mais là comme vous l'avez
peut-être remarqué depuis le début de
cette vidéo je suis en pleine phase de
recherches pour trouver un lieu coule
pas là depuis presque six ans dtcc ici
que ça se passait j'y retournerais
peut-être de temps en temps mais je vais
changer de décor
ce sera peut-être là pas sûr ou
peut-être sera là non plus n'ont sinon
peut-être sérieux là non alors sinon
j'avais pensé à un truc un peu aller
n'importe où mais bon moi je cherche des
trucs aussi - oui bah c'est non oui bon
bah de toute façon ça ressemblera plutôt
à un truc comme ça voilà oui c'est chez
moi t'es ok bon bref je bosse là dessus
et je vous tiens encore mort mais
pourquoi pourquoi changer en fait il ya
deux raisons mais on va se poser un
petit peu pour en parler parce que j'en
ai marre de courir partout là la
première raison c'est une envie de
changement tout simplement c'est bien de
se remettre en question c'est bien de
bouche de temps en temps pour pas
s'encroûter pour palace et pour pas se
lasser soi même ensuite parce que je
change deux trois trucs dans ma façon de
travailler je change de modèle
économique déjà comme on dit quand on se
prend pour je sais pas qui parce que
vous en six ans il s'est passé plein de
trucs donc est notamment le co vide et
ces deux dernières années ça pas été
très facile de continuer à gagner de
l'argent sur tout en gardant une
certaine ligne de conduite alors oui je
sais l'argent ça fait pas le bonheur
mais bon on va pas se mentir en général
les gens qui disent ça c'est des gens
qui en ont suffisamment et puis le truc
c'est que bat pour faire des vidéos il
en faut de l'argent gratuit il en faut
aussi pour payer des trucs genre ton
loyer des courses et quand on faire des
vidéos c'est un métier à plein temps
passé aussi ta seule source de revenus
par définition il ya un truc qu'il faut
savoir c'est que je refuse assez souvent
des partenariats pour des raisons
éthiques parce que j'ai pas envie de
mettre en avant certains produits ou que
j'ai pas envie de m'associer avec
certaines entreprises certaines marques
etc et même des fois tout est clean tout
est complètement nickel juste je sais
qu'il ya des gens qui vont trouver des
choses à redire et des gens qui vont
causer voilà donc je préfère éviter
parce que on va pas se mentir au bout
d'un moment ça fatigue un peu j'ai vu
tout ce qui s'est passé là depuis deux
ans c'est un peu la crise pour tout le
monde donc ça se bouscule pas vraiment
au portillon du coup c'est devenu un
petit peu compliqué
bref je suis pas là pour pleurnicher
c'est pour moi comme pour tout le monde
depuis deux ans il s'est passé plein de
trucs qui ont eu des répercussions au
niveau perso est évidemment mais aussi
au niveau pro je vais pas m'appesantir
là dessus parce que c'est pas le sujet
de la vidéo mais on peut reparler
évidemment d'ailleurs je vais vous
proposer un truc je vous dis ça à la fin
de la vidéo mais ce que je peux déjà
vous dire c'est que je vais faire deux
trucs que j'avais pas fait jusqu'ici le
comte sioux type déjà dont je vous ai
dont je vous ai parlé et puis d'autres
types de partenariats que ce que je
faisais jusqu'à présent à savoir des
vidéos sponso par des marques qui n'ont
pas de lien direct avec le sujet genre
vous allez sûrement voir apparaître des
petite intro au début de mes vidéos ou
chez vous les deux coques de téléphone
de jeux mobiles etc voilà vous
connaissez c'est le meilleur moyen de
pouvoir continuer à faire les vidéos que
je veux à être indépendant si vous
voulez et c'est aussi le meilleur moyen
de pouvoir continuer à choisir
soigneusement les partenariats sur des
sujets dédiés voilà donc rien de
révolutionnaire vous avez déjà vu ça un
peu partout mais comme vous aviez jamais
vu ça ici encore t'es pas je vous
préviens et je vous explique mais encore
une fois pour celles et ceux que ça
intéresse de rentrer dans le détail
rendez vous en fin de vie ensuite un
autre truc qui est déjà vrai depuis un
moment mais qui va être de plus en plus
vrai vous allez pouvoir me retrouver
ailleurs que sur youtube pour des
contenus un petit peu différent de ce
que je fais ici mais si vous aimez dtc
vous avez aimé ça aussi donc abonnez
vous à mes autres réseaux sociaux pour
voir tout ça et quand je dis réseaux
sociaux je parle de instar tik tok s
book twitter et cetera je vous mets tous
les liens dans la dans la description de
la vidéo donc n'hésitez pas vous aurez
plein de trucs que vous voyez pas ici
sur youtube moi ça m'aide aussi et puis
c'est une autre forme de rapports entre
nous et puis at which aussi alors je me
suis mis à un an pendant plusieurs mois
j'ai fait pas mal de live et puis plus
trop pour plein de raisons mais sans
faire de promesses que je pourrais pas
tenir j'ai envie de reprendre et même et
là vous allez voir l'enchaînement
incroyable et même pas plus tard que le
17 février
2022 pour faire un débrief de cette
vidéo pour répondre à vos questions pour
parler de la suite etc oui voilà c'était
ça le truc dont je vous parlais depuis
le début de la vidéo enchaînement de où
je suis michel drucker en fait donc si
vous avez des questions à poser si vous
avez envie d'en savoir un peu plus sur
les trucs que j'ai fait que survoler par
exemple ou sur autre chose je vous donne
rendez vous le 17 février 2022 donc je
vous donnerai l'heure
un petit peu plus tard parce que j'ai
pas encore fixé sa
du coup bas raison de plus pour vous
abonner à mes réseaux sociaux puisque
c'est par là que je veux que je vous
préviendrai mais en tout cas noté la
date 17 février on va discuter de tout
ça tous ensemble on va discuter de plein
d'autres trucs aussi si vous connaissez
mes lives vous savez comment ça se passe
et si vous connaissez pas c'est
l'occasion venait et avant de se quitter
petite piqûre de rappel si vous voulez
me soutenir sur youtube je vous mets le
lien dans la description et je vous le
mets là aussi oui alors là je vous
montre du doigt mais comme mon bras
bouge pas depuis une photo on va
imaginer quoi voit la dtcc fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite sur
twitch si vous avez suivi mais aussi ici
pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là prenez
soin de vous et prenez sont les autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]